what's up everybody welcome back to
GameSpot Crosse kind of funny I'm Greg
Miller this is the producer slash to do
store Nick Scarpino and this is the man
Devon so hello everybody hey Devon sighs
are you doing so nice having you all had
to be here thank you for coming thanks
for having me
we brought you on because we love you
blush it starts with me with idle hands
okay huge idle hands fan yeah [ __ ] you
mean I mean my friends watch it every
Halloween you pot smoker no no wow I
know
so usually people stop me to talk about
idle hands like I wish that was always
thing I watch your career progress of
course that never was an idle hands to
which sucked I'm not gonna blame you
though yeah but eventually one day yeah
you started talking to me on Twitter and
asked years ago yeah yeah I was like
what is going on and then Eric Goldman
from idea was like well he's a huge
video game fan video game comic books
all that kind of stuff
I love it so what are you playing right
now what is happening you're like I'm
playing anything right now the last I
know I know the the last one I play was
battlefield
what is the Medal of Honor put the
campaign's I don't go online because
those kids those kids spanked me within
30 seconds yeah I'll be super meme use
yeah your mom now you know they don't
know what jerks and stuff yeah so what
do you want to see d3 then I wanted I'm
staring at the star wars battlefront III
meant battlefield by like I'm staring at
Battlefront that's my face at
battlefield battlefield
okay how's well I've been stabbed a lot
that's I'm like that's been my focus I
want to go there and and try that game
yeah looks so amazing I saw online oh my
god yeah you gave it did you give up
yeah we did
we got three awards apiece to go to the
game that we picked for the best gaming
show okay I gave it one to one I can't
even talk right now
I mean on devon Sawa I gave one to
Battlefront of course right largely
because I didn't even play it it's just
large because I'm a huge Star Wars fan
and it's a foregone conclusion that
game's amazing so I'm just like giving
one I'll play it when I can sit down in
the comfort of my own home cuz it's not
the optimal playing environment anytime
you get like I like they give you 10
minutes to play it and you get a match
you get a whole round that giant it's a
you go over
there you're playing on HOF you're
running around while you can Vader fight
in the front there's TIE fighters and
you got to get over there yeah okay yeah
well I mean if you waited for like four
hours - but you're Devin so go over
there with the kind of funny badge
you're devon Sawa and that's kind of
funny they send you right for the pretty
sure that that's gonna get him kicked
out if he comes with any anything with
our name on it comes in the last three
days we've been [ __ ] on the floor
that's what nobody else has a crowd is
location pick it right right do
everything for a company that's five
months old we're doing pretty well yeah
can't complain yeah yeah so what else is
happening in your life in my life like
work-wise like alright oh I see you got
your kids a lot too I love my kid it's
not a kid year and a half you think
that's one of the reasons you haven't
played games as much maybe yeah maybe
yeah Brandon Routh was in here saying
the same thing really and this is why
I'm anti kids won't have kids is gonna
cut into your video game Moriarty can
you get devon Sawa water you're the only
one oh no I mean there's Grayson grace
is on the move call don't worry y'all me
grab it no no we hired Grayson for a
reason
I think it was to run the room but he's
gonna water we're good I'm hydrated I
got a lot of coffee in me it's very very
hydrating Nick's not the opposite is
that why I can't think right now
it's gonna be fine I'll be fine all
right so what's happening you have the
kid the kid that's awesome in a year now
that's amazing they just like they say
your life is gonna change
yeah you know he's the best thing ever
I'm tired of talks starting to discover
things wrecking everything of course um
working tonight you great uh thanks man
appreciate it did a few movies that are
coming out this fall what are they
that's a sick Punk - okay I don't know
it's it's uh it was just a con yeah well
yeah people like it good life on the
line with Travolta and Sharon Stone and
Kate Bosworth is coming out in the fall
yeah and then there's a movie a small
moving for Fox also coming out it's a
sequel to Molly Hartley okay but we
didn't really we just forgot about the
first one kinda and just started over
really and that cuts off all - so that's
awesome
you're doing things you're doing things
for a while and yeah that was that it
was awesome but thank you yeah Eric
Goldman loved the key yes because it's
Nikki and it was one of those shows were
like I started watching it just because
I'm not a huge fan of Maggie Q obviously
who isn't and then you pop up and I'm
like what
blind blown I guess obviously you love
idle hands slackers is one of my
all-time favorite movies movie - love
that movie and you in it you were
phenomenal in it so you are you were
great on that show thank you here's what
happened
yeah somewhere along the line you were
like oh I'm gonna go to the gym and get
super yolks Wow how did that happen I
start wife was like start super big yeah
and then I got on set and I tried Maggie
Q convinced me to become a vegetarian
around no approach all the proteins went
out and I was eating beans and like it
was it was a mess it's like that's 160
pounds and and then last season I was
like you know literally I think it was
one of the first few uh few episodes
you're tied to a bed yeah she like
kidnaps you ties you to bed tries to
reprogram you and you're just he's just
yoked out and my wife's like I'm gonna
need you to leave the room yeah and so I
had to leave the room so you have an
intimate relationship with my wife you
don't even know it but probably a lot of
people's wives say no that's the thing
and I we got it where we got to point
this out okay is that when we said
you're coming on right oh my god I'll
hand that every woman we talked to
flipped out my girlfriend is here yeah
looking beautiful she had not come to
one she is never set foot in this room
that one days Brennan Roth was just
changed I know I don't know why she
doesn't like Brandon Roshi's apartment
great looking man yeah yeah but you pull
you pull a very good crowd of women we
have all of our friends over here man up
you have Bernie from roosters oh my god
chloe dykstra from chloe diary nice to
meet you I'm strapped well you don't
shake my hand you don't mean what you're
you don't do anything you didn't have to
do anything yeah nice yeah we got we
have my
we're ahead of you this is a crowded
couch we said how do we end a three and
we said devon Sawa and the most
beautiful women Plus Christine off
camera see what I did it will capital
make it work can we make that much Kevin
if you like this job this is amazing
have my Brittany mic on now Brittany
three guys here like they all came I'm
speechless right now I don't know what
is that everything all planned out I was
I knew where I was going with his noun
speeches so do you dude is it I guess is
it weird still being like you're like
everyone's like I don't like for so many
different reasons like these girls like
love you and I've gone full creep
thank you very much for the images that
ran through everyone's brain when you
said that just now maybe which is me I
don't know it was really creepy
now and then they were just saying the
idle hands it's the different
demographics I do want to point out
Anthony Carboni really wanted to come to
this as well he wants to just do not on
his podcast I'm damned oh you got to do
with me you okay
hi here I'm your agent now exactly
exactly
maybe what's your favorite I definitely
know in the weird about it yes and
Casper I think half right now and then
are the two like girl yeah that's yeah
Casper that was mine that was definitely
mine I was obsessed with Casper a
ridiculous way to bring up on San Giulio
in your lyle but let's talk about what
you did when you were 12 that's the
thing is that weird or endearing or what
anything no it's great yeah flattering
yeah the ghost I love goes there you go
ghostbusters didn't work on you but okay
oh I don't know that worked on me too
okay I was all about that too I think my
favorite interaction was we were eating
pizza and you're like hey I'm friends
with Devin
let's tweet him and then you tweeted us
back and I cried I actually cried that's
one Jessie was like oh man it's great me
like it might be alright he's a great
guy to follow on Twitter so what else
what Coach you you get a chance to play
Mario maker
hey just here right now he wants to play
back all right real quick remember he's
doing hot pepper game in battle room so
it's gonna be online you're gonna do the
hot pepper gaming thing apparently
you're doing it Willie would you like a
green pepper pepper habanero Mario
making you scream dominate he has to go
see Mario maker oh my it's so much fun I
mean you get to create levels and then
you get to play what you just created
like it is freaking fantastic I'm gonna
say hey Mario maker ever Star Fox
no no it's you're making Mario Mario but
yeah right yeah I have the ultimate game
for you it's over in Southall it's
called butt-sniffing pugs I'm an indie
game yeah that you play it's true Blaire
you each play as a pug right you have
superpowers right to get the other puppy
of different superpowers to get the
other bugs superpowers you have to snip
it's fun
and then you just interact with the
environment it is the most incredible
game you play with a giant tennis ball
is your control is it higher than mobile
PC okay and then there's a wild I don't
think I know how we could ever be a home
thing you'd have to buy a giant I was
gonna ask you about that have you been
to the Sony booth over there best part
is she's the but you have there's a
plush dog but you've to spank just sniff
the other dog's butt oh yeah well guys
video games
shut him down I wouldn't play that with
hololens actual
it's what's great head it's super
old-school it's an indie game that's
what you had to do try everything
alright
Lego Dimension X link pilot yes just
play Lego dimension that's where I'm
going right after this okay I can't wait
what Lego dimensions it's amazing yeah
many if they got it's like you know
Skylanders or Disney infinity yeah it's
like that now these are the Lego guys so
I got like a Lego Marty McFly he can
smash everything with his guitar Lego
just imported all of these franchises
and output video games it's really cool
their games are really well done dream
come true yeah yeah bash them so they
have like Batman and a Mystery Machine
like you can match all the universes
together a different way now your child
what your child child yeah very young
yes but your have when are you gonna
introduce video games when he was going
on yes I posted playing really
sure do you think it'll be are you
worried that he's gonna knock yeah
exactly the cutest thing ever that's a
little too Duty here yeah maybe for you
kids I don't I have a lot of Legos and I
play a lot of Call of Duty so we're all
of giant kids we are our own children
you're definitely in the Isle where no
one grows up yeah but I love watching
kids play games because they play so
differently than we do so you know at
the Nintendo Championship they had a kid
commentating right oh yeah super cute so
having a child's perspective of things
that you know we are playing now is it's
fascinating yeah love it
Nick yes do you have movie questions for
the movie star Devin sour I I did until
everyone came up on stage my brain just
went blank really like to have a very
important question I guess you what was
it like kissing Jessica that was coming
like that movie that movie defines my
childhood it defined me leaving
childhood into a different place and I
just I just caught it right it was great
I think we all want to know what it was
like he doesn't have you don't have to
answer that that was amazing the 19 year
old Jessica Alba was Beau's awesome now
that's what it's like for you too this
is this your first
III yeah what is it like to walk in and
see all of these crazy booths and all of
these games it looks interesting I can't
wait to actually get out and look around
mom it's pretty massive yeah a little
smaller oh really now yeah there's two
of these buildings it's crazy yeah and
there's yeah and some of the games that
you're talking about some oh yes many
get them fun you're just gonna wait in
line
sniffing dog's ass [ __ ] game was good
yeah yeah that's so fun did you do a lot
of these events there's this sort of
just now I don't usually do any events I
don't see this was my excuse when I
don't know how he got me here really oh
it was that game so he's like he's never
done a comic-con he's blinking always
somewhere like like the last time it was
for Nikita and I was I can't remember
what the reason was but I don't know you
need to stick with this guy you need to
get out I don't know if I wanted to I
think I I came into this zip for the
next five years I've done right on
gamespot hey funny we wanna you know you
to do this and you build the stage out
it was just an excuse to hang out all my
la friends yeah cuz I always have so
many la people my god I'd love to have
you on the show but you never come to
San Francisco when I come down here I
shoot something in leaders yeah we're
supposed to come to San Francisco and
that didn't work out either you so can
anytime
all right it won't be like this out
there I mean it'll still be a train
wreck and Nickleby weird I don't have
some excuse for why so weird
it's the I want to eat this thing so bad
so are you finding yourself able to
still work at the pace you want to even
what the kid is it tough leaving no it's
it's fine it's but it's worked out good
yeah his mom is really good she come up
you're in a passion I got much to say no
I made her think it was really boring
here oh good no way I can go play the
video game sure yeah you have to worry
about her yeah plus somebody should
watch that kid right trap cams now
sleeping with a drone
do you play any games right now or
nothing right now the last play the last
time I play was battlefields campaign
other than that I have enough time do
you have a favorite console or ps4
that's it I used to buy both of them I
just have the Xbox and the ps4 and I
found myself just playing PS you know
whatever was history yes yeah that's
right yes Peter
whatever have you looked at Uncharted at
all I haven't yet that might be
something you might be interested in its
we're only at four so there's not that
much catching up to do have to play one
two and three - no I don't - you did
yeah and it was great she was one of the
finest games I've ever played before
what they were telling me is I was
talking about it Neelam Bruce and they
were saying that yeah like if you play
the other ones you don't understand the
relationships better there's Easter eggs
and stuff like that but if you want to
jump in here you can jump in here oh
cool yeah yeah plus they're putting out
the collection now right they're gonna
put all three games out one ps4 nice
great great can I have a copy yeah you
want something from PlayStation
- how many he wants a guy behind you in
the white t-shirt his name's Nathan
Vella give him a water and say it's from
me thank you oh right yeah yeah cap it
for BAE a sports no no use caffeine okay
I told him the pinch you're asking a
pinch right let him pinch your button
there you go
this show is so defeated while he was
pinching his but you know I think that's
against the law but I'm not quite sure I
only care about things like that do you
want to come shake Devon sours hand I
have another question
wait video another fan another fan named
novella camping every time someone opts
on I see like the YouTube video of us
all crashing Devon I have a question for
you you don't go to conventions a lot
right now so what do you think of this
sort of thing we may also by the way
they're not just cosplayers they plant
awesome rock and roll music yeah oh who
are you cosplaying yes sir actually
we're the band's song hammer so we're a
rock band who does fight songs for geeks
explain yourself that's right I was
playing in that stuff I don't know it
actually well is what it is because we
we do music for Blizzcon and we perform
at San Diego comic-con and things like
that so Devon is this super foreign to
you the idea we all this is bizarre
thank you cosplay rock it's a new city
or your fan yeah we're uh yeah we both
sing full-time sometimes I'm right now
we don't do I smell the burning of
villages at dawn no room for weakness in
yeah I dare you to find a more
entertaining booth
there are plenty Greg there are funny it
was going really gonna go right through
the center of the foot it's just gonna
have Thank You Man
good luck whatever that was awesome we
made a lot of jokes about water and we
got 15,000 of them that's on Nick of
course real thirsty I came up here yeah
but I don't think we didn't need the 19
waters he had Grayson bring I'm a great
you know it if you give him a break for
just one second okay it rots him out you
got to keep hammering him down like a
bad nail Grayson you were great this
week our production assistant Grayson
get up here and take a bow thanks
Grayson we're winding down still gotta
make demonsaw be to hot pepper and then
giveaway game of the show whatever but
look at Grayson you really don't wave at
the camera wave right you don't wave at
the TV wave of the camera now I just
seems interviewing you how's it going
doing great
are you stressed out or the one-foot
policy you can't get that close sorry
interview over okay what is going on
right now
no just the ranting for you so where
we're all used to this random week all
week yeah we have Brandon round today
right we had Shuhei Yoshida president
Sony worldwide studios
okay we had the two guys who make
uncharted Neelam Bruce we had Troy Baker
who's the voice of wanna try to go hallo
guys what your first guest from Tuesday
at first oh yeah Cisco is our
he's touring still he's a huge video
game fans but I'm intended album write
himself from Baltimore out here to be
our correspondent right ran around the
show floor saw a game for us I think
blue back to do some more concert stuff
did he sing for you no I don't I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna or do you think it's
enough now wait for just like a Jessica
Alba question I like you waiting for I
keep your door how was it with Jessica
Alba I hit that bingo that big ol girl
immediately you're still working to
that's the other yeah we were talking
actually the YouTube party I was like
you're still doing things so when we say
like now and then are Caspar like it is
not because that's all you did you have
done so much more has that affection
that's so nice it's just our childhood I
watched him on Akita like two years ago
and he took his shirt off and I was like
hello my wife go awesome work if you
guys seen about Nikita
it's amazing you should watch it if you
have not automatically easy actually one
of the things that I wanted to ask you
about was like the one of these about
Nikita that was so awesome was the fight
choreography right you were kind of a
[ __ ] badass yeah how long what was
that process for you like do they bring
someone in do they sit you down do they
have to crack things over your hand you
have to get tough I took a five-year
break from after slackers till when I
did Nikita and in that time I went to
Southeast Asia and we're more Thai I
came back and started boxing and
wrestling and all the stuff with Emily
she was one of the reason that I came
back into the business they asked me to
come back yeah
I was like okay and one of the reasons I
hired me for the kids cuz I had a
martial arts background yeah sold that
yeah yes we've learned the steps on on
on the day like right before we shoot
they'd be like it choreograph it a
little bit and a few times we need to be
on the ball did you were you kind of
instrumental in teaching some of the
other people that they knew were people
like a lot or cuz I guess they already
had training before everybody had a
little bit of training she received did
you come into season two I came in I was
in season while you were in season 1 and
then I came in as a full regular in
season 3 right 3 3 and 4 I was regular
but I was bouncing in and out 1 and 2 so
you actually went to Thailand to learn
more each time I didn't go to learn it
there I went over to vacation my way up
there for 3 months kind of traveled
around Thailand Vietnam Wow
and I went there's like a little side of
the road touristy Muay Thai thing I went
in and I tried it and I came back and I
continued it like 5 6 7 years I'm still
doing it now yeah really yeah that's
awesome
I let sued you Oh Joe Rogan's podcast
all the time so love Joe Rogan and he
had John Wayne parang who was a big Muay
Thai guys magic I just now imagine you
sleeping on a mat in Thailand on the
side of the road right actually I wish
you a fancy hotel and then came back
early enough to roll up your mat like
you're there all night do you have a
favorite MMA fighter
oh man is so many question the answer is
GSP I won't yes we're both Chris Weidman
right now yeah and there's a boy
laughter had that stuff I love a big fan
of MMA so yeah John Jones for a moment
and then jump oh my god fall from grace
no come back
he won't though he had there was like
he'll come back he'll come back he'll
come back
he hit a pregnant woman and he left well
it seems a accident come back it'll be
huge money for a big comeback it could
be I just felt like there were it was
just like a little trip a little trip
and then so many and it was like you
really think
when he first started it was like
remember that story about him chasing
down like a mugger MMA is boring